ragdolls hilarious
I can't stop laughing look at him go
today we're playing human fall flat so
in this game you can customize what you
want to do and your character you can
customize your character guys so
recognition got a hit
Jesus Christ that's Jason Bourne yeah
yes I'm 12 how do I take the [ __ ]
picture
Jesus Christ that's terrifying dude
oh my god all right apply that [ __ ] man
all right we haven't even played the
game yet so let's do that now wow they
all see how you are you just have to say
that you're fine and you're not really
fine you just can't get into it because
they would never understand I walk like
I [ __ ] my pants which is how I walk
anyway they say thank you well I'm going
to kill myself oh I'm stuck this is like
a metaphor for YouTube oh that's how I
get up in the morning
well then let's uh let's go in here man
[ __ ] this is a meta [ __ ] man let's push
this one then we'll press an Andy button
yeah yeah all right I'm ahead of you
already [ __ ] up I think I have to push
this away right there you go yeah
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ]
all right now we're gonna ah this is why
everyone clicked on the video to watch
me solve puzzles this this game is
surprisingly lackluster where the hell
am I
oh god um yeah yeah doesn't what we call
a matrix move yeah god I look depressed
this really is a youtube simulator dude
this is easy this game is too easy for a
brilliant mind like I am I'm so some
what the [ __ ] are you doing okay can I
get some epic music I get some serious
epic music thank you I'm gonna make this
jump
wipe selfies sweat
and he goes nailed it
oh [ __ ] oh Sh
I've done it now okay
bucks
my videos are painful enough already I'm
not gonna play any more puzzles don't
worry I got more games let's go all
right let's start with 10 meters salad s
come on salad ace yes there it is go
salad s go salad ass he's got a great
form look at him look at him he's just
[ __ ] now that takes Talent and he
finishes off by pumping the air but
Peppa Peppa he's flying
he doesn't need to run he needs to fly
go salad s I need some serious music now
this is a salad Aires life depends on
this he's been gambling in the wrong
wrong neighborhood what the [ __ ] are you
doing salad ass salad ass you [ __ ]
ass come salad ass wants to run so much
but God does not let him run oh [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is that salad ass oh now
he's trying a new technique this year
apparently my name is palette ass and I
am the fastest man alive
oh my god I'm I think salad ass
just [ __ ] snorted some so no 7s
solidus no get up get up get I don't
know what is to always back up don't let
move salad
woo salad that's right
that salad you always bet on the salad
always bet on the salad that's what my
mom said salad always bet on salad
so that was rag duel runners that's a
cool game man ragdoll games so fun am i
right what did I tell you at the
beginning I need I need boots and a
thumbnail surely there's a game about
boobs and rag doll come on come on Papa
needs a new Lambo come on come on this
is a calculator boob necklace that's
funny
that's a boobs coloring book that's
hilarious there's a boob ice luge
that's hilarious oh you can drink from
it hey you want to look like a piece of
[ __ ] and we got you covered man now
we're talking all right what's my
location okay we're gonna have to add
like a fake location I'm in Gothenburg
okay that worked oh wow it's a game
about boobs
after silicone
what do we want mama's got a new package
Oh
from that angle there's always that
weird gap isn't it they asked me how are
you to say that you're fine you're not
really I think we're gonna have to turn
that episode there I think we're gonna
have to end it there rag rag rag doll
boob physics I'm like all fun Klaus
rates I'm a mastermind in military
achievement filthy Nazi nurtured
Norwegians fine I just send the past
bye-bye
my name is Barry Allen
they ask you how you are you just have
to say that you're fine and you're not
really fine but you just can't get into
it because they would never understand